histoire mais je sais c'est très marrant
et à dieu mais dès qu'on voit et
pourquoi tu réponds pas comment je peux
savoir que tu me parle à moi on est 500
ici ok on joue deviner non qu'est ce que
c'est ça j'ai dit non et ben moi non
plus ils vident renoir chuchoter moins
fort c'est lui chef il arrive pas je te
demander ton avis book alliance
non c'est plus fort que moi on attaque
en chef
on sort quand la nuit tombe elle tend
quand tous les jours je sais quand elle
tomberait à midi on est là depuis 20
minutes
si vous continuez de parler dans une
heure on est grillé en brochets et on
finit un sandwich grec parce que nos
ennemis sont des grecs
ok de prendre la mouche la mouche tais
toi toi papa
voilà pourquoi y'a quoi qui moi oui toi
nantua nantua n'entre même pas moi
citoyen entre nantua la non non c'est
toi j'ai tué
lui c'est lui moi oui tous les toits je
suis pas sûr de vous que ce soit mon
avis c'est aussi parce tout cas si
vraiment il fait trop tout noir giflés
vous tous je trouve pas celui qui
apparaît alors giflé vous tous mais on
peut pas tous
tout ça fait tellement trop de dépêchez
vous sinon je vais commencer à mettre
des petits coups de glaives au hasard
dans le vide
et comme il fait tout noir eh bien ce
sera pas de ma faute si je vous plains
tous
j'ai fait mon affaire voilà maintenant
fermez là ça va être long mais tu sais
pourquoi veulent leur faire la guerre en
fait donc je crois qu'ils ont capturé
une de nos femmes est attendu un moment
le renault facile a dit hélène de qui la
tiennent un qu'il empile tranquille
avons notre cause a à g bien pipi génial
tu attends les toilettes vient bien sûr
a dit si tu étais toi mon fils à papa
chef et c'est ainsi que le ciel conclu
est moins fort et c'est ainsi que le
siège dans le cheval de troie avant la
taxe se déroule en tout cas d'après tes
chaussettes